[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
happy Tuesday everyone and what a great
Tuesday it is so sag after the union for
actors claims that their profession is
about as dead as a Critic of Hillary
Clinton
it all has to do with AI replacing real
live actors which seems redundant of
course replacing Hollywood actors with
artificial intelligence is like
replacing Vin Diesel with Vin Diesel
but remember they've done worse they
once replaced humans with real
housewives that didn't turn out well so
here's the Union's warning quote without
a transformative change the acting
profession will no longer be an option
for future generations of performers and
actors who will need to pursue other
careers in order to survive
so we're going to lose future
generations of performers which sucks I
was really looking forward to insulting
kilmead's grandkids
but it's already happening I had pizza
delivered to my office today and this
was the driver
so thanks to computers acting could
return to what it was originally
something anyone could do as a part-time
job like being an Uber driver or vice
president
now now
I'm not sure which side to take let's
take a look at who's defending the
performers none other than that bug-eyed
alien Satan himself Adam Schiff who
slinked out of his pod with just enough
oxygen to blow it out his trap
all too many people back in the Congress
think that everyone who works in this
industry is some multi-millionaire
celebrity when the reality is these are
folks that are just trying to put bread
on the table uh keep a roof over the
head
fair enough but they get no help from
him who made that state unlivable for
everyone but the super rich former
Paramount CEO Barry Diller is warning of
an absolute collapse of an entire
industry
so what's the bad news
I mean when cars replaced horses I'm
pretty sure the buggy whip industry
collapsed except for the ones I order
every year for leatherfest
what's going on did I go too far but
that's what happens when progress brings
new options and you try to sell us old
stories that are married to woke
lectures I mean everything out of
Tinseltown is a more putrid version of
something that we used to appreciate
they take something good and they turn
it bad like what Kat did to her husband
I'm cold
and it's not like the audience needs
more content every year Hollywood turns
out more crap than the view during
broccoli season
in 2022 they produced 599 scripted TV
shows if my math is correct that's
almost 600.
[Laughter]
that's up from 210 in 2009 it was so bad
that during covet I started wearing my
mask around my eyes
so maybe this strike is giving the
audience a breather where we can catch
up on what we should have watched years
ago like The Rockford Files the guy
lived in a trailer in a parking lot but
unlike Jimmy phela he was only acting
or Columbo you always wore a raincoat
even when the sun was out fun fact he
did it to trap the farts
but imagine if they remade that they'd
call them Columba and under that
raincoat he'd be wearing a thong
but now minus ideas they just pollute
Classics with politics like this that's
Disney's upcoming live-action remake of
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
and no it's not bigoted of me to say
dwarfs we get to say the d word to each
other
but it's more like snow off-white with
the seven guys from a drug rehab in
Seattle
hey look like they're friends who say
they just need a place to crash for a
few days and then they sell all your
furniture for drugs
but those picks are so embarrassing at
first Disney claimed they were fake then
they admitted they were real but not
official yet too bad Pinocchio didn't
make that statement he would have been
hired as the new spokesman for Viagra
but the woke are happy changing
everything can't I can't wait for
Dumbo's ear reassignment surgery
but mess with Snow White and they're a
product of their own demise I mean how
can you have sympathy for this devil I
long for the good old days when Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs really really
could say what they wanted remember this
holy that's Snow White she waking up
everybody hide
oh goodness I'm so hung over
oh
actually how much money would you pay to
see them my Coke habit has put me in a
lot of debt anyone got a dime bag we
could do some together we can't afford
Coke lady cause you're poor that's so
funny it's okay we can have gasoline
[Applause]
God I hand it to him they really did
call the balls and Strikes meanwhile as
Hollywood starves from creativity they
ignore sound of Freedom that's the
anti-child Trafficking movie that's
outselling the big budget bomb Indiana
Jones and the Crystal bedpan
the left hates its side unseen because
no Christians can be allowed to do
entertainment meanwhile they can't do it
either maybe they're scared that the
God-fearing folk figured it out and can
do it better and who knows maybe movies
just starring machines well that might
really work out think of the romance
they came from different sides of the
kitchen he was just a no-good down on
his luck toaster from Target she was a
sexy unpredictable coffee maker from
Creighton barrel and together they made
hot sweet breakfast
but when a Sleek microwave moved into
town things really started to heat up
will someone get left out in the cold
will this romance short circuit or will
this unlikely Trio prove that love can
happen anywhere find out this summer in
continental breakfast
ah
you don't need people
but if Hollywood's looking for love they
come to the wrong school board meeting
regular people are tired of being talked
down to about their beliefs their jobs
and most of all how they raise their
Dwarfs
listen
people say he stinks oh stuff box across
America Jimmy Fallon
she's my favorite Molly that's still
legal editor-in-chief of the Federalist
Molly Hemingway
foreign
hydrogen TV Rider and producer Rob long
and she's like an overcooked steak kinda
tough and popular with fat guys Fox News
contributor captive
[Applause]
boom Rob used to be a Hollywood guy and
they're like coming along you think I
got off the yacht I can tell yeah I kind
of like that's my new look usually you
call me a hobo yes but I think I'm
getting promoted here you kind of moved
into the skipper uh category of
Gilligan's Island speaking speaking of
that yeah yes yes so what do you think
about this uh this the the coming ruin
of of all the industry used to be part
of well I you know I I like to think
that I'm still part of it I'm actually
in Sag you know I'm a sag member I'm a
writer skilled member and a Director's
Guild member so I'm like two-thirds of
me is on strike and one third of you
made a deal that's how I think of it
um look uh you you're the the graphic
set at all there's just too much there's
been too much of everything and there's
no way for these companies to make any
money they've done a terrible job
running these the people running these
companies have done a terrible terrible
job
um there's no no one ever said to
somebody Hey listen you want a good
steady Dependable paycheck go to
Hollywood right it's always going to be
uh crap shoot right
um and I think what's gonna have to
happen is it's gonna have to get much
smaller gonna have to have less of less
stuff on which is fine because there's
still only like a few hours a day to
watch TV I mean right most Americans
don't watch as much as you watch and so
well they watch my show over and over
again Rob yeah they call me the the new
cheers yeah that's that's right I've
heard that what do we do now are you
smelling toast burnt toast what's going
on
um you're okay right yes
um so I look that's what's gonna have to
happen giant disruption is going to take
place and actually it's going to be good
disruption is good and by the way
Hollywood's been through this a lot it's
designed that Hollywood is actually one
of the best Industries to face change
better than the car industry or the
computer industry and any of those
places that this is going to be you know
rough year uh and then it's all going to
be much much better and a lot of these
guys running these companies now will
not be running them interesting Molly I
know that it's easy to have no sympathy
for Hollywood right but there is I mean
I hate to say it Adam Smith did make a
good point that like it's not about just
the actors and the or the the directors
or just these hanger ons like Rob it's
like the the Carpenter and the people
that run the Wardrobe what do you say to
that yeah I mean you look at this and
sometimes you're thinking it's like the
Iran Iraq war where you just want both
sides to kill each other and that yes be
good for the country but yeah it's
actually this one of these industries I
cannot this will be like the one time I
agree with Adam Schiff quite the actor
himself but when he was talking about
how there are a lot of people who just
like normal working-class people who are
working who need to have some stuff
renegotiated and it's a big industry so
hopefully and there are things that need
to be updated you have all the streaming
issues you have ai issues the contract
should reflect that yeah I guess so I
don't know I just think that I don't
really think that they've ever changed I
think they only virtue signal speaking
of old con uh oh here it comes no no old
content uh do you uh do you miss new
series because they're on strike no
because there was such a proliferation
of shows like there's so many shows out
there right now like at this point I
spend more time reading about my options
than I do watching stuff I read about 50
Series and then just log off yeah 45
minutes you're sitting there doing this
and then you hit it and then it goes and
then it just takes forever it's beyond
they've made a sequel to everything I
was watching a rom-com the other day
called love handles actually I'm like
wow these people are a little chubby and
now watching like porch Pirates of the
Caribbean it's not good
here's where Adam Schiff is wrong
because I have empathy for the
struggling guy yeah but Adam schiff's
like they just want to put bread on the
table I'm like dude they're actors they
can't have bread no that are you talking
exactly they just want to put cocaine on
the table then you would have had me yes
dumb especially in that jacket yeah
people don't know if I'm set if I see it
for real when I walk the streets of New
York like this people don't know if I'm
selling drugs to Fox Talent OR I am Fox
Talent obviously the answer is both uh I
wouldn't go that far let's just say I
think it's a great jacket oh thank you
and it looked really great on Judge
Jeanine about it
love it yeah
Kat are you excited for the Snow White
remake
I don't get excited for anything
uh I I was
they keep doing remakes this one it was
funny they said that they consulted with
the dwarf Community the dwarfism
community
did you
because I mean no one called me
but also like I'm sure there's some
people who are you know would not care
it's not like that's a monolithic group
right there's some people or dwarves are
like I don't give a I'm trying to go to
work right now yeah you know what I mean
it's always this people don't want to
look at people as individuals right and
I think that people also don't want to
see a new Snow White that much
and I certainly don't yeah it was kind
of I think like growing up as a kid I
always found it kind of creepy didn't
you I mean it was just such an unusual
relationship the witch was really really
really scary to me but that's because I
was raised very Catholic and told that
witches were real and potentially after
me but I mean the whole thing is weird
what's she doing living with seven
little guys it's just an odd thing and
they're and you am I supposed to believe
that they're platonic
they're all little perverts
oh yeah like this is the one thing it's
non-threatening though when they're
dwarfs yes you know it's just cute she's
walking around with dwarfs like look at
that right there that just looks like a
a Subway sexual assault waiting to
happen
like that's the part that bothers me but
this is the part where wokism really
ruins the things it pretends to want to
help yeah okay they got rid of the
dwarves in the name of inclusion but
they're making it sound like the dwarves
were stealing all the acting gigs in
Hollywood yeah dude they had Game of
Thrones and this yeah yeah it's a very
long line for one role we're just
looking out for you so we're gonna whack
80 percent of the job market yes come on
man terrible
um yes we'll be there for you whenever
we have any roles a Gutfeld that require
dwarves
we're just using dwarves or me hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else